thanks to the latest research into
violent expiratory events or sneezes
we can now observe in very close detail
the turbulent multiphase cloud which
distributes a payload of droplets and
mucosal ivory
or well stringy gobs of spit at high
speeds and over great distances
these gross but engrossing images are
made possible by highly sensitive slow
motion cameras which can track each
single speck of snot
this is high-tech stuff but the
fascination with sneezing and the
attempt to capture and examine the
sneeze is actually as old as the moving
image itself
this short film known as fred ott's
knees was recorded in 1894
to test a new moving picture machine
called the kinetoscope
this five second long film showing fred
ott taking a pinch of snuff and then
sneezing captured the imagination of a
public who were wowed by the idea that
something as fast as a sneeze could now
be captured preserved and repeated
of course sneezes were also an object of
fascination long before the cinema for
the ancient greeks sneezes could be an
omen from the gods
according to one ancient roman doctor
sneezing during sex could be used as a
contraceptive
but the most common interpretation of a
sneeze is probably that you might be
getting ill
but it was not until the late 19th
century that the idea that infectious
diseases can be caused by microscopic
pathogens was introduced
it was this new understanding of how
diseases spread along with the global
shock of the spanish flu pandemic in
1918 that spawned the public health
messages that we know today
like coughs and sneezes spread diseases
[Music]
it was the development of stroboscopic
photography in the 1930s which really
brought this message home
this work led by the mit researcher
harold edgerton used short sharp flashes
of light to seemingly freeze time and
analyze all sorts of high speed
phenomena including the humble sneeze
images like this one helped us to
understand the raw power of sneezes and
to think about how we might protect
ourselves and those around us
an infectious disease can be dangerous
at any time but the prospect of a wave
of viral infections was particularly
worrying to public health officials in
the uk during the second world war who
were keen to protect the health of those
working in the war effort
wartime propaganda made good use of
these stroboscopic sneezes to persuade
people to cover their mouse and wear
masks the germ mask is a simple way of
keeping the germs at bay get one and
wear it now
[Music]
in the age of sars and coveted 19
cutting edge technology is still being
used to try to better capture and
visualize the mechanics of the sneeze
maybe an even fuller understanding of
exactly how sneeze works will help us to
use tools like masks and social
distancing more effectively in the fight
against epidemics but it's not only
researchers who are continuing the long
tradition of filming sneezes
a quick search on a video streaming site
will bring up homemade footage from
vloggers and filmmakers all capturing
these explosive moments for themselves
the image of the sneeze is with us to
stay yes it can provide us with useful
information but it can also be a comic
punchline a tool for persuasion or just
a source of fascination
it's something that is common to us all
yet it is also so strange spontaneous
and fast that we never really get to see
it
maybe capturing it on film repeating it
and slowing it down gives us a measure
of control or at least the illusion of
control that we can't have in real time
and so in well over a century since fred
ott sneeze in some respects our viewing
habits haven't really changed so much
after all